hi there Steve Kaufman here again I'm
going to continue talking about the
subject of the started with my
discussions with Benny the Irish
polyglot and this is this whole question
of how effective a method it is to just
go to a country and start speaking there
now there are a lot of defenders of
Benny who kind of look at me as some
kind of a nasty ogre for not buying into
Benny's stick and and I guess Benny is
more in tune with the culture of the
Internet again the Tim Ferriss look at
me Wow oh and maybe to some extent I do
that I don't know but I as I pointed out
in another video where I talked about
the importance of being judgemental I
like to form my own opinions and I like
to express them so when the subject is
that as Benny puts it and I and I'm
quite happy to talk to him again and if
I'm putting words in his mouth he'll
he'll certainly he'll certainly correct
me but to him the best way to learn a
language is to simply go to the country
and start speaking to people and within
three months you'll achieve this level
that is you know one of speaking pretty
well as he puts it so a number of people
on my blog the linguist on language and
have pointed out that it's pretty
difficult to start speaking to people if
you don't have any of the language and
of course this is my point that you're
better off to start with some input I
don't deny that speaking is a useful
thing to do and eventually you have to
do a lot of speaking if you want to
speak well but I just don't think that
it's a practical or even a helpful bit
of advice to just say to tell people to
go to a country for three months then
you'll speak well and there are a number
of reasons why I don't agree with this
but one that comes to mind that I think
is quite important is languages you
don't learn a language
three months languages go through a
lengthy gestation period to that extent
languages in my experience of having
learned now I speak 11 languages I've
attempted a few more but it takes a long
time and in fact you sort of go out a
language for a while and then you can
leave it and even it's been my
experience even when I'm not working on
that language it actually improves
what's more the things that you try to
learn now let's say today are within a
three-month period there's no guarantee
in fact it's unlikely that you aren't
going to learn them just because you're
trying to learn them now you'll work at
them now and they won't click in until
six months or 12 months later I have
that experience all the time so to say
to someone your task is a three month
task I don't agree with you know his
idea is gonna go here for three months
and somewhere else for three months sure
if you have Spanish you can do
Portuguese in Italian not a problem
that's almost like staying within the
same language once you get into you know
check for three months and then tie for
three months and then try going to
Russia or China those three months
stints aren't going to produce very much
in my opinion no I don't I can't say
that that it doesn't work for Benny I'm
just saying I don't think it works for
many people just this morning I was
listening to a Spanish podcast which is
the Copts a radio from Spain and they
interviewed the Archbishop person who is
now the Archbishop of Valladolid in
Spain but who was for 15 years the
archbishop of Bilbao and so the
announcer said to him can't remember his
name said and of course you are fluent
in Basque aren't you and the archbishop
said well I can celebrate Mass in sin in
Basque in the Basque language it was
Scott er whatever it's called
I can celebrate Mass in that language I
can read with the help of a dictionary
and I can map when a defender un poquito
I can defend myself a little bit
now that's after 15 years now I'm sure
that the Archbishop of Bilbao and today
of my elderly is an is an educated man
an intelligent man he was probably
motivated to learn probably not
sufficiently motivated but he's not
untypical of what happens when people
travel to another place and even though
he had lots of contact with people who
spoke Basque and he celebrated Mass and
Basque he can only defend himself a
little in Basque okay then he I'm sure
if he went to Bilbao in three months he
would do better I don't deny him that
but I'm just saying that it's not
something that I would recommend to a
lot of people I go back the idea that
you're better off to prepare ahead of
time now many says he does prepare ahead
of time because he reads his phrase book
on the plane going over so and he said
there's two hours I guess if you're in
Europe most places are two hours from
Dublin so that's fine two hours that
experience is totally different from
mine if I read a phrase book for two
hours or for ten hours I will not retain
many of those phrases very few and if I
were to use them I would trigger an
avalanche of language back at me that I
wouldn't understand but I have trouble
learning phrases from a phrase book I
have lots of phrase Brooks I've tried I
can't remember them and I find that
again it's back to what I always say you
know dealing with interesting content
that the read and build up words and
phrases much the way we do at length
there's the reason we've devised it the
way we have it you'll reach a point
where you say now I want to go to the
country and if you go at that time you
will have a much more productive
experience and I want to get back to see
this idea of languages in wine I speak
all of my languages
better today than I did when I studied
them that includes Chinese even though I
was a full-time student in Hong Kong for
eight months I did nothing but learn
Chinese I had no one to talk to outside
of my room and outside of my teachers
but I speak it better today I found that
after nine years in Japan and and
speaking Japanese all the time my
chinese improved not initially I was
rusty when I went back to it but by
listening to audiobooks and by reading
it came back and was stronger than ever
but and I found this with all of my
languages but one of the reasons is that
I've from time to time refresh them and
I refreshed them by listening to
audiobooks or podcasts or by reading so
I developed a learning technique that
enables me to maintain my languages and
which which I find them as I say
improving with age and I suspect that
this is because my brain becomes more
flexible as I learn more languages and
so my ability to to find words and to
express myself in different languages
improves so that like old wine the
longer I've been out of language the
better I am even if I don't use it all
the time so that's another reason why I
think that sort of a hidden hit and run
strategy and I don't want to
characterize it or miss characterize it
many will certainly quickly disabuse me
where you say you go there learning
learning language in three months you go
somewhere else and learn a language in
three months I don't think most people
will learn the language in three months
and I think it's a technique that makes
it difficult to you know to take
advantage of this aging process that I
find is a big part of language learn you
need first of all you need to put a lot
more time into it than just three months
you do need to do a lot of listening and
reading so in order to really become
comfortable in the language and the
other just one other thing I will touch
on Benny was going on about how
difficult it is from going going from
Spanish to Portuguese and it's really
more difficult than we think it's not
it's the same language that you have to
pick up on a few differences but it's
90% the same vocabulary you can get off
the plane in Brazil from Spain and you
can understand what people are saying
and you
communicate from day one now some people
will lose their accent some people won't
I was listening to a podcast in
Portuguese on tsf and they interviewed a
Spanish professor lady who was a
professor at the University in Portugal
and she was speaking Portuguese and she
made absolutely no concessions to
Portuguese pronunciation so that she is
as if she was speaking Spanish but she
was speaking Portuguese words pronounced
a hundred percent like a Spanish person
would and different people react
differently some people simply stay in
the comfort of their own you know native
accent but the languages are essentially
you know as close as can be I'm gonna
run out of time here but I just leave
you with this thought language learning
takes time and it as you age and as the
languages age they get better and it's a
lifelong study and a very rewarding one
just like drinking a old aged bottle of
wine can be thank you very much for
listening